um es auf den punkt zu bringen der
physik rennt die zeit davon das
standardmodell der teilchenphysik konnte
zwar immer weiter perfektioniert werden
dennoch träten die forschungsteams in
diesem bereich seit jahren mehr oder
weniger auf der stelle
neue spektakuläre entdeckungen bleiben
aus beispielsweise sind die sogenannte
dunkle energie und dunkle materie
weiterhin so rätselhaft wie eh und je
doch das soll sich jetzt ändern und zwar
mit dem neuen phaser experiment des cern
leichte extrem schwach wechsel wirkende
teilchen die man bisher vielleicht
übersehen hatte sollen so nämlich
aufgespürt werden lösen wir damit jetzt
endlich die zahlreichen ungelösten
rätsel der physik alles zu dem neuen
experiment jetzt bei pixum science
fiction hier gibt es täglich
faszinierendes eines videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
herzlich willkommen dieses phänomen
macht wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler die sich mit der
physikalischen grundlagenforschung
beschäftigen wirklich total verrückt die
rede ist von der sogenannten dunkle
materie die licht wähler aussendet noch
reflektiert sie ist unsichtbar und noch
nie hat sie irgendjemand direkt gesehen
oder nachweisen können doch obwohl sie
nicht direkt sichtbar ist macht sich
dunkle materie indirekt eben schon
bemerkbar
und zwar durch ihre schwerkraft die
ganze galaxien um sich kopiert und die
auseinander fliegen würden wenn es die
dunkle materie nicht gäbe den gängigen
theorien zufolge ist dunkle materie also
durch ihre wirkung als eine art
klebstoff dafür verantwortlich dass wir
überhaupt existieren denn sie hat nach
dem urknall dafür gesorgt dass sich
normale materie überhaupt zu galaxien
und sternen verdichten konnte mit
dunkler materie in verbindung gebracht
werden dunkle photonen gemeint sind
damit quasi die doppelgänger normaler
lichtteilchen diese dunklen photonen
endlich aufzuspüren ist der traum vieler
physik teams und der könnte vielleicht
schon bald in erfüllung gehen und zwar
mit hilfe eines neuen experiments die
forschungs kommission der europäischen
organisation für kernforschung cern hat
jetzt das go gegeben konkret sollen mit
hilfe des so genannten phaser
experiments leichte extrem schwach
wechseln wirkende teilchen aufgespürt
werden
die der forschung bisher ja im wahrsten
sinne des wortes durch die
lappen gegangen sind phaser steht hier
übrigens für forward search experiment
die fachleute sind sehr optimistisch so
endlich die heiß ersehnte neue
entdeckungen zu machen die die vier
haupt detektoren des large hadron
colliders lhc möglicherweise einfach
nicht erkennen können denn es könnte gut
möglich sein dass die gesuchten teilchen
wie eben die dunklen photonen einfach so
aus den direktoren entlang des lhc
entweichen und soeben bislang unentdeckt
blieben
konkret soll der phaser detektor 84
meter vom atlas detektor entfernt seinen
platz finden
hiermit hatte man am cern das higgs
boson nachweisen können der plan des
kerns ist clever der phaser detector
soll immer dann aktiv sein wenn das
atlas experiment läuft denn die
wissenschafts teams gehen davon aus dass
die neuen bislang unentdeckten teilchen
dann entstehen wenn die proton
strahlenden interaktions punkt des atlas
instruments passieren
die protonenstrahlen werden dabei durch
magnete auf eine geschwungene bahnen
gelenkt leicht nur sehr schwach wechsel
wirkende teilchen würden ihre flugbahn
aber in gerader linie einfach fortsetzen
zudem gehen die forschungsteams davon
aus dass die neuen teilchen nur wenig
gestreut werden der phaser detector
könnte sie dann also registrieren
das instrument soll laut plan einen
durchmesser von rund einem meter haben
und dabei nur etwa fünf meter lang
werden im vergleich zum applus
instrument also ein echt kompaktes dinge
die andere experimente des cern sollen
von dem bau des phaser experiment aber
nicht gestört werden das instrument soll
deswegen in der gerade stattfindenden
wartungspause des lhc gebaut werden um
kosten zu sparen und den bau zügig zu
ende zu bringen sollen laut plan
ersatzteile verwendet werden diese
werden von den atlas und lhc
experimenten bereit gestellt schon ab
2021 sollen dann daten gesammelt werden
und das zwei jahre lang und das ist
langfristig gesehen auch nur der anfang
ab 2024 soll nämlich der größere fässer
zwei detector installiert werden dieser
könnte die entdeckung weiterer noch
unbekannter teilchen möglich machen klar
ist jedenfalls dass der weltgrößte
teilchenbeschleuniger lhc in genf die
physik weit nach vorne gebracht hat
unter anderem 2000
durch den nachweis des higgs bosons doch
seitdem verlief die suche nach neuen
teilchen weitestgehend erfolglos das
phaser experiment ist ein neuer versuch
endlich kandidaten für die äußerst
mysteriöse dunkle materie oder aber
super symmetrische teilchen aufzuspüren
dazu cern mitarbeiter eckhard elsen das
phaser experiment ist eine gute
möglichkeit der physik außerhalb des
standardmodells auf die schliche zu
kommen
ich freue mich dass das so effizient
umgesetzt wird quantenphysik die
grundlagen von doktor watson
draufklicken anschauen und abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran